[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct pleasure of sitting today
with tristan
harris who is co-founder of the center
for humane technology and the host of
the center's podcast your undivided
attention
tristan welcome to darkhorse it's great
to see you brett good to be here with
you
yes it's great to be here with you uh
just so that people understand where
we're coming from you and i
know each other prior to either of our
podcasts we're friends
and so we've had a lot of informal
behind the scenes discussion about
topics that i'm sure we will get to
today
um you are in the bay area am i correct
yep in the san francisco bay area uh
after a brief sojourn um due to a
climate
uh outcome of our house burning down due
to the wildfires in california in
september so
issues of uh anyway that's just the
reality of my situation i'm back in the
bay area
very yes that sounds slightly beyond
what we usually think of as a climate
outcome
you know the earth is getting warmer but
it's rarely hot enough to catch your
house on fire geez your house burned
down
that is um shocking well the crazy thing
is that the
we obviously don't have to go into this
much but the house burned down
two weeks after the release of the
social dilemma which was this global
sort of phenomenon so actually i had
less than
24 hours between that happening and then
doing the today show at you know five in
the morning and continuing to do
interviews and
you know everything that was happening
because the film the social dilemma was
seen by
something like 100 million people in 190
countries and in 30 languages
so it's it's you know balancing all that
after the house burned down and being
sort of on the road and having to work
it all out was was just a
a unique experience to have
yeah that's uh that's remarkable
i should say i was going to mention your
amazing netflix documentary
anybody who has not see it should
absolutely seek it out and watch it it
will tell you
a lot about what's been on your mind and
why i thought it did a very good job
of putting flesh on the bones that are
sometimes
hard to get people to to see
where you know everyone has a sort of
vague sense
of how big tech works and what influence
it may be having on things like our
collective sense making but very few
people have
any idea of what the mechanistic
underpinnings would be
so um the documentary did a good job of
um of outlining that you want to say
anything
about um what the
what the core message of the documentary
is
yeah i mean uh you know the film is
really um a message about
the people who are inside the technology
companies you know justin rosenstein
who was co-inventor of the like button
at facebook and the person who brought
the business model of advertising into
facebook and
early employees at twitter at facebook
at youtube etc
saying you know this business model is
fundamentally misaligned
with the fabric of society being healthy
and
the you know it does that by by
explaining how the same
problems that are with the technology
companies are really part of our
economic system
that a economic logic that lives on an
infinite growth paradigm on a finite
substrate you know usually it's the
planet
causing climate change in this case we
have an infinite growth economic
paradigm of big technology companies
based on a finite substrate of human
attention
and that i think that the film is really
summarized in justin rosenstein's line
at the end
that he says so long as a whale is worth
more dead
as whale meat than alive and a tree is
worth more as two-by-fours
than as a tree in our attention economy
uh two technology companies human beings
are worth more
as dead slabs of predictable human
behavior than as living breathing choice
making
meaning making you know you know
semi-free-willed
humans and that that logic is really the
core
of where you'll see lots of problems so
shortening of attention spans political
polarization
um things like this so
of course as an evolutionary biologist i
see all of these things and i find
no end of analogies to my home territory
and i try not to drag people there more
than necessary because
if it's not your uh your home court
it it you know it adds an extra kind of
step to one's logic but there's so much
here
you know i'm used to situations in which
a very
small advantage over enough time
results in the modification of creatures
and what we have here with respect to
the attention economy
and big tech algorithms etc
is not so subtle influences
operating over a short time but with
completely predictable results and the
answer is it doesn't really take
very much if the signal is consistent
it doesn't take very much to drag
belief for example our shared narrative
which is so necessary to us functioning
as a society it doesn't take much to
drag it
um into some territory where it serves a
private interest at the expense
of the public and you know
i think if people realized how delicate
the assumptions were
on which normal functioning depends they
would be less
shocked by how distorted things have
become in light of
these novel influences that even if they
were well intentioned
when they were originally constructed
are just simply incapable of maintaining
the uh the foundations of thought
yeah yeah the um
i think the breakdown of our shared
reality
due to a profit motive in which
personalization is profitable
this is really important and subtle to
get i mean it's sort of obvious once you
see it
but giving each person their own truman
show reality
is more profitable and better at keeping
your attention glued
than to creating shared realities that
are not personalized a
personalized twitter with a personalized
algorithmically curated news feed is
going to out-compete
a chronological twitter that just shows
you tweets showing up
on you know whatever level they do so it
really becomes this race to
hyper-personalize which then this race
to narrow
each of our individual construction of
reality and i think that is actually the
deepest harm
that i like to focus on these days
because that's really what we're seeing
i think in january 6 we're seeing it in
the country we're seeing it around the
world
we do not have a shared basis of ground
reality i know you talked to
our mutual friend daniel schmuckenberger
about some of these topics uh but i
think that is the kind of shared
um problem statement that we're now left
with i sometimes think of it right to
sort of
play with metaphors that you are and
heather are
are talking about that we now have a few
different problems we have a
technological problem
of how social media's business models
and fundamental design and virality and
kind of hijacking of all of our
different evolutionary
impulses causes all these sort of you
know
cultural fallout this kind of cultural
externalities of
shorting of attention spans mental
health problems of kids etc
and this breakdown of reality but now we
have a cultural set of problems the the
problem is metastasized so now if you
took technology away
our minds are all running you know not
that they were never not running malware
but they're running much worse malware
than they would have
ever run before and it's been
exacerbated so i think of it kind of
like we had the zuckerberg institute of
virology
and that institute was doing gain of
function research
on mimetics on what kinds of memetic
viruses would work and they were
literally having engineers tweak things
like
you know the news feed recommendations
you know which kind of things would keep
people clicking more and they started
evolving
hyper-evolving in a certain pathway in
the same way that gain of function i
guess research
kind of works they were also tweaking
the friend recommendation systems to say
oh
which friends could we recommend for you
to add that would cause you to stay in
the product longer and more friends like
you more like-minded
friends more q anon friends if you start
off in humanon more wokistan friends if
you start off in wikistan more magistan
friends if you start off in magastan
that will increase people's sort of
tribal affiliations then they were doing
gain of function research on facebook
groups what
groups could we recommend you to join
and
um we now know from facebook's own
internal documents that 64
of the extremist groups that people
joined were due to facebook's
own recommendation systems in other
words this was not a user who's going
into facebook and being like what group
what sewing club what book club do i
want to join you know what dark horse
podcast discussion group do i want to
join instead they're being recommended
something and my friend rene diresta
who's sort of a researcher on these
topics
says it really perfectly when she was a
new mom she joined an organic
baby food moms group like where you make
your own baby food
sort of a natural thing you might want
to do um but what was the most
recommended group do you think for the
new organic baby food moms
from facebook's point of view what would
keep people what would people what would
keep users
who looked like organic do-it-yourself
baby food moms on the site the longest
if you're just
building a naive ai recommendation
system
uh i am frightened to guess
for many reasons um i'm going to i'm
going to resist guessing because
i i will tell you if i'm right here in a
second
you tell me what it was i mean it's not
maybe that surprising that it was more
of the anti-vaccine moms groups right
because that's
exactly what i was going to guess and i
didn't want to
i didn't want to say it because i didn't
want to add fuel to the fire
right right yeah well so
um so and then once you joined that
group then facebook said oh well what
do the anti-vaccine moms groups what do
they tend to click on that's what keeps
them around the most and it recommended
pizzagate and chemtrails and other
things like that now when i say this i
might sound like
a blue church left person who's saying
oh all these conspiracy theories and all
these sort of
hesitations that people would have are
somehow naively informed as opposed to
there's a pre-trans fallacy for each of
these different
sort of concepts and i want to make sure
that we're caveating that
but when you understand that this gain
of function research zuckerberg
institute of virology
was doing this research that was hyper
accelerating
these kinds of um evolved pathways and
now that that
that memetic virus that sort of reality
dividing virus that extremifying reality
virus left the zuckerberg institute of
virology in menlo park and actually
escaped into the world
and it actually has shut down the global
sense-making ecology
it is now just in the same way that
covet has shut down the global economy
i think that this mimetic virus has shut
down our ability
to see reality in shared ways and i
think that's really the problem is how
do we
not just deal with the pandemic but how
do we deal with the kind of reality
breakdown pandemic and how do we
have not just like reality bridging
conversations but really what is the
the solution to that and i think we're
all trying to figure that out
all right i want to slow down a little
bit because it happens that you have
landed
uh just like a millimeter away from the
topic i was going to introduce here
and get your thinking on it so i know
we're very close to the same page here
but one of the things that i think is
most difficult to convey
is that there is a natural
synergistic relationship between
human consciousness and creativity
and evolutionary dynamics that we are
unaware are taking place
and so i think we have you know there's
a dichotomy a false one
where people expect ai to take off
and come for us but they also
intuitively know that that can't be
where we are because all of the devices
that are supposed to be intelligent are
way stupider than they should be
right so we sort of know that we've got
some time before
ai gets to that place however what we
don't intuit
is that humans can partner
with semi-artificially intelligent or
narrowly artificially intelligent or
even just learning algorithms and they
can do the part
that the artificial entities can't do
themselves right so you have a bunch of
people inside facebook
thinking about how to enhance facebook's
financial well-being
right just increase shareholder value at
this point
and they can narrow the search space
of possible functional strategies
to a very small a very small canvas
and then things like a b testing
can do the heavy lifting which is
incidentally you've landed on the
perfect analogy
it is exactly gain of function research
because what gain of function research
does or not all of it but the part of it
that is called serial passaging
involves taking a natural entity
or a largely natural entity or a
composite of natural entities
and placing it in an environment so that
evolution can do the stuff we don't yet
know how to do
right if we could do it directly we
would
but we can't so what we do is we just
put it through an accelerated
process of evolution we basically reduce
the noise and increase the signal
and then we take what comes out the
other side and we discover
what we didn't know enough to to desire
so that is exactly what will happen here
but imagine you know you could have had
a thousand facebooks right a thousand
hopeful companies starting out trying to
capture this space
and selection would have found the ones
that
happened to have the right things to
keep attention on their site
right to direct people to stuff that
would reinforce their
their their biases etc those companies
would would have risen to the surface
instead
we had a couple of facebook-like
entities but we had intelligent people
within them
looking for mechanisms you know how does
facebook get ahead of myspace right
and um that has been
like a cyborg
where you have a partially
undirected process of evolution and
partially human creativity
fused together to discover defects
in all of our cognition that allow them
to
steer us into behavior that we otherwise
wouldn't
be involved in and you know
it is i think the thing is if you
understand
that this isn't wholly dependent on an
evolutionary process that is haphazard
nor is it wholly dependent on a
conspiracy in which people
simply sideline human well-being and go
for broke
but the two things can partner it would
be hard to overrate the danger of that
and what you've been saying forever is
effectively
it's here and we don't actually know the
full
uh range of hazards that emerge from it
yeah that's
that's exactly right i'm so excited to
have this conversation with you because
i don't get to talk to evolutionary
theorists where we can really go deep
into
um each of the sub aspects of this
problem um
the first thing you talked about was
this sort of projecting into the future
we often look into the future and say
when is ai going to take over
humanity and we think about the
singularity you think about numbers like
2050 2060
you think about you know super
intelligence nick bostrom
you think about ai taking our jobs but
there's this much earlier point that
you've made
i know ages ago in your work i remember
you and eric weinstein both your brother
eric talking about this
more like the accession point that
technology doesn't actually overwhelm
human strengths that undermines human
evolutionary weaknesses
and there's a sort of takeover point and
by the way that point for me is more
informed by my training and magic um uh
actually since the house burned down
i've been buying back all my sort of
magic supplies
all this sort of these packages arriving
with these kind of interesting magic
goodies and the interesting thing about
magic is it's based on an asymmetry of
understanding
where the magician essentially does know
something about an evolutionary weakness
in your mind that you do not know about
yourself and it's that asymmetry of
information
that allows the illusion to work and the
problem is that technology
has become this sort of 24 7
hyper asymmetric magic trick but we
don't perceive it that way because we're
enjoying so many things from it
we enjoy social validation and approval
we enjoy
uh getting you know variable schedule
rewards slot machine type things we
you know we enjoy um photo filters that
make us look more attractive briefly
but these are all essentially um
exploits
maladaptive depending on how you see it
exploits on
key evolutionary weaknesses and it's
really a race
this is where the phrase the race to the
bottom of the brainstem it's a race to
the deepest evolutionary weaknesses or
as your brother has said a race
to create a backdoor to the human soul
to figure out and reverse engineer
whatever would we would call sort of a
dimensionality of free will to turn
more and more of those dimensions into
predictable outcomes
meaning less and less free and more and
more commoditized dead slabs
of human behavior um it's really
important to get this because i think if
you if you go back and like you said
it's not
a conscious intention by facebook or
twitter to try to ruin the world or to
profit
greed at all cost i think a lot of this
was incremental decisions in an
evolutionary environment where they're
competing for attention
you know i actually remember because i a
lot of our insights about this work come
from
knowing the people who built these
products i was friends with the founders
of instagram
i was at south by southwest in 2009 when
facebook was competing with twitter for
who's going to create the news feed and
they're both competing for that
chronological kind of instant news feed
of
people posting things really often and
having it feel more alive and more rapid
and a news feed that's giving you new
things constantly is going to
out-compete a news feed
that only has new things once every five
hours right because there's a freshness
to it
so in each case um and i hope we go more
into this
the the race to capture attention led to
um
all sorts of decisions being made that
were based on the evolutionary fitness
of attention-grabbing machines but not
for the evolutionary fitness
of a societal cohesion or a societal
intelligence
because what i really worry about is
that the net results of all of this is
when you don't have a shared reality or
an ability to agree on reality or you
have
such emotional grievances and
resentments because you've seen
infinite evidence of hypocrisy and awful
things the other side has done
that you do not want to you don't even
want to have a conversation about what
you could agree about and what you can
do about any existential problem whether
it's climate change et cetera
that have shrinking timelines so when
you kind of add this all together
the question i'm always asking is what
is an attention economy
what is a digital environment what is
the cyborg-like fusion
of the man machine human machine
interface
that leads to a smarter democratic
plural
you know collective psyche but is making
better and better choices
together and i think because we have
limited time on various problems
especially climate change
that's the real question that i kind of
land on but we probably should reverse
engineer a little bit more of how we got
here with the
evolutionary hacking of tech sweet now
unfortunately when i talk
to uh to you and a few others
each you know little soliloquy opens up
you know
10 12 hours worth of topics that we
could cover and so there's a bunch of
stuff i want to recover here and i'm
sure we're going to miss
some important things let's make sure we
try to capture a lot of it though
because i think it's going to be good to
to flush out
yeah i think it's really important stuff
one has to do with magic and i wanted to
point to something that you didn't
exactly
say but i'm pretty sure you'll agree
with
the thing that's really fascinating
about magic it's not so surprising for
reasons we can come back to
that human perception has blind spots
and defects that can be exploited
right but there's a big difference
between
running into a con artist who you don't
know is a con artist who is attempting
to exploit those things for their gain
and a magician where you go and the
person says hey i'm a magician i do
magic and you know damn well they don't
do magic
right but the point is you you are
constantly at a good magic show trying
to figure out how it's being done
and unable to right and so the point is
the fact that you're aware of what's
going on at facebook twitter etc
is no protection and this is one of the
things that i think
is most telling is that the very people
who constructed these things
the smart ones are aware that they are
not in control that when they are the
users they're as vulnerable as anybody
else
and you know the fact that they very
often have
uh very strong limits for their own
children's interaction with these things
tells us what we're dealing with we're
dealing with something so potent
that um the awareness that it is
happening is no protection
and that and that's what's so dangerous
right because it means that there is no
sort of safety
place where we actually still have
control because as
you know in the film the social dilemma
tim kendall who
you know is a father and has a couple of
kids and talks about how he was
promising himself that he wouldn't use
pinterest he was the president of
pinterest
and he found himself in the pantry you
know scrolling on pinterest ignoring his
own children he said this is classic
irony i'm the one who's building
pinterest on a daily basis it's like
getting high on your own supply
he can't get off the thing even though
he's making commitments to himself
to not do it and that's actually one of
the parts of the film that i think
people
really latched on to um aza raskin our
my co-founder at the center for humane
technology talks about how he actually
wrote himself
software to um you actually will
appreciate the intervention that he
created
to make himself less addicted to twitter
and to read it you know the way he did
it brett
is he actually um created a random
slowdown so as you used facebook or
twitter or reddit
more during the day it would actually in
a variable random
level slow down how long it took for
pages to load if you say
do you you know if you put a time limit
and put a seat belt on and say just like
apple does in screen time
you can't do this you know don't don't
look at more of this you know you've hit
your 15 minute limit
your brain just gets upset at that and
says no no get out of my way i'm going
to keep going anyway right you're not
the boss of me
you're not the boss of me right that's
not that's the same paleolithic emotions
that sort of come up in that
context but if you do a random slowdown
where it just gets slightly more
frustrating not a lot more fresh it
doesn't take forever it just gets
slightly more frustrating
over time and you just your brain
eventually it gives your brain enough
time to catch up with its impulses your
prefrontal cortex can catch up
with your sort of emotional impulses and
you know when you're making this
metaphor of you know we're losing
control it's almost like the inmates are
running the asylum but really the
amygdala is running the asylum our kind
of reptilian brain is running the asylum
because if no one has control and no
one's prefrontal cortex
gets to sit in the pilot seat of our
sense making and choice making
and instead we're left more and more
with the lower parts of ourselves
then that's the representation of where
you know all of civilization goes
because
when you zoom way out and this is when i
was a design ethicist at google prior to
to doing this work my biggest concern
was that you know we have three billion
human beings
who are jacked into this real you know
instantiation of the matrix you know we
say like
we actually did build the matrix it
doesn't look like it did in the movie
and at least in the movie version of the
matrix we had a shared matrix whereas in
this matrix we have we have our own
different
hyper-personalized truman show matrix um
all right awesome this is this is
fantastic all right let's go to the next
part of
of what you raised uh before so we've
got
magic which demonstrates that the fact
that you're aware of
of uh these defects in your own
perception is really no protection from
having them gamed but you also have
um let's open up the parallel realm
okay the parallel realm i would say is
the world of optical illusions
yes i was just thinking the the the gray
the checkerboard right where you're
going to go with this
uh i was going to go with the general
category so i would say
that the world of optical illusions
which is now
effectively a realm of academic
study is all in search
of evidence of how we perceive
things based on there may be more
categories than this but at least two
categories of phenomena one
where some heuristic and we'll come back
to what heuristics are in a second
but some heuristic in our perceptual
apparatus decides
something is one way or it's another and
a
carefully presented set of data can be
perfectly ambiguous between two
possibilities and therefore the brain
you know to the extent that you know
some prior bit of cognition
or the way the light falls suggests one
way
right it sees it that way and then if
something changes you may see it the
other way so you know these uh
sculptures are they convex are they
concave
the necker cube you know are you looking
at which corner of the neck or cube are
you looking at
there's those things and then there are
other heuristics where
when something shows up so you know we
have a frame rate in the eye many people
will claim we don't have a frame rate in
the eye because the frame rate isn't
regular in the same way that a movie
film would be but
but we do clearly have a frame rate in
the eye which is why
for example when a car with perfectly
regular wheels drives into the parking
lot you may see them turn backwards
because
they advance not quite to the position
of the
other spoke uh you know in one
click of the frame but in any case
you've got all of these cases where
something in nature if your retina saw
it at this position and then that
position
it would be safe to conclude that it had
moved
right so now if we flash things in a
particular way the mario
brother appears to move through the
scene but in fact all the mario brothers
are perfectly static
anyway the point is that is exploiting
a perceptual heuristic to cause the
brain to conclude
wrong things right that you can then
test are wrong
like the checkerboard case that you show
where the two squares look very
different in hue
based on a gradation but in fact you can
check that they're identical
so anyway what i want to get at is these
heuristics are there
for your well-being right in fact
they're the key
to any rational perception if you tried
to perceive
every pixel on your retina and process
it you just
you'd never get through a frame right
it's just too much data right so you've
got to break it down into chunks that
are so reliable
that you just get a huge payoff for
using a subset of the data to draw the
full conclusion
and it's very rarely wrong but the fact
that these things are riddled throughout
our perception
means that a magician or a
person who is interested in creating
optical illusions
or a corporation that is interested
in keeping you on their site all
find them right in other words they're
littered through your perception for
your well-being
but they are exploited by others all too
easily because of their ubiquity and
predictableness
so the question is without an agreement
that hey it's not cool to game other
people's perception i mean maybe it is
cool if it's a surprise party
and the point is you're going to enjoy
the surprise party when it's revealed to
you so i'm
it's okay for me to you know to take
advantage of your trust briefly
but this is a good example of that with
michael douglas
say it again the film the game is a good
example of that with michael douglas
where you could have a
entire false reality constructed for you
that then the end of the movie is
the curtain gets pulled off however
you've been thrown through the ring or
you thought you almost died and there's
this question of
what is an ethical sort of false reality
or manipulation of someone else's
experience
if you know one way to do as you're
saying is you sort of reveal it at the
other end there's often transformational
experiences or cults or transformational
workshops which actually do more
confrontational alternate reality
creation by manipulating your experience
but then they say at the end it was all
for your benefit and there's this
i'm saying this actually because what my
motivation for this work which i don't
often talk about but when i was at
google as a design ethicist
the basis for this inquiry of how
technology is impacting society
has to do with what is an ethical
asymmetric um
manipulative a persuasive relationship
when something
is influencing some of your evolutionary
weaknesses
in or outside of your influence and when
is that
a grounded ethical humane relationship
um because uh in the the degree of
asymmetry between what technology knows
about you that you do not know about
yourself
is going to grow the number if you point
an ai at your brain you think of the
news feed as like a
kind of a chess game where your brain is
the chess board and you think you're
going to scroll one more video or watch
one more thing
and then you're done and you think
that's going to be it but you have this
asymmetric ai that's playing out a
trillion simulations from all the little
human voodoo doll animals that it's
the human social animals that had seen
used facebook with the exact same usage
patterns like it's seen a thousand other
people watch those same cat videos where
a thousand other people
watch those you know brett weinstein
podcast and it's seen what is the next
thing that i could show you
that would get you to stay and it knows
way more about that than you are
aware of it because it's literally ran
more simulation so the degree of
asymmetry
over time is going to grow which means
that we have to actually have a
relationship with something that knows
more about us than we know about
ourselves that is ethical or grounded or
humane
and that brings us to we shouldn't
escape the topic of rinse i'm not trying
to diverge so i know we keep opening up
threads
but you then ask what are other
relationships one party knows way more
about our psychological weaknesses than
another you might think about a
therapist
who is licensed who says hey i'm going
to know your deepest you know secrets
i'm going to know your deepest
you know vulnerabilities your biggest
concerns your you know your inquiries
for yourself your sexual identity your
relationship how you feel about your
romantic partners
they're going to know all that
information and they can't go use that
to manipulate you so you spend more time
in the therapy room or
they can't use that to sell it to some
advertiser so that someone can basically
say oh
you have these kinds of anxieties guess
which political party would love to know
those anxieties that i would want to
target you
so once we see it in that way this is
both opening up an inquiry but i think
we can
we can leverage insights from different
fields whether it's psychotherapy
counseling
law you know a lawyer knows everything
about your vulnerabilities in your case
more than you know about it and you have
to trust that agent
to act on your behalf and so gosh
there's so many things that we can open
up here but where you get to in
technology is you simply cannot allow
categorically a business model based on
exploiting that asymmetric relationship
what i like about this framing is it's
kind of a one-and-done way to simply
nail the business model and say it's
super clear you would never have a
therapist whose business model could be
advertising to political parties to
manipulate you based on what they hear
you know in the therapy room or you know
a a priest who's sitting in a confession
booth who listens to two billion
people's confessions
literally like all the things that they
know about you then they have imagined
worse than that the priest has a super
computer next to them it's literally
calculating patterns of all confessions
they've ever heard
so they're actually making predictions
for the person who's about to walk into
the confession booth before they even
say
the confession that's on their mind they
know what that confession is going to be
and they can sell that to
another party this is the kind of
asymmetry of power we now have
and so gosh i know we're opening up so
many different threads because we can
still go deep into the evolutionary
stuff and the cognitive biases and
there's so much the same
there but uh i wanted to make sure i
brought that in
yeah uh fascinating and you're right so
many interesting threads but
let's uh let's see if we can nail down
the the
point that you and i are converging on
here there is
either a basis for trust in the case of
the therapist there are actual
regulations there's ethical regulation
ethical being about the rules of
psychology for example that say for
you know just to take one example here
your therapist is not allowed to sleep
with you right there's some sort of
waiting period after you've left therapy
before
your therapist could start a sexual
relationship with you right that's a
protection because this person as you
point out knows all about you
and therefore would be in a position to
manipulate you right right
and then financially speaking there is
an explicit contract that you have with
this person and so
those protections i don't know that they
work or they don't work but i know that
the point is to establish a basis for
trust that you actually know what it's
made of
right that's right and then there's
another kind of situation so let's say
that this is the
flip side where somebody is bound to you
in a way that your trust isn't about the
rules but it's about the fact that they
don't have an
interest in using this against you right
so family members for example
you know heather has uh
i don't know that we've ever explicitly
even talked about it but it's very clear
to both of us
that she has the right within limits to
lie to me
for our collective well-being right so
for example if
you know i'm up against a deadline and i
need to get something done
uh and you know our collective
well-being is
dependent on it she may adjust what it
says in the calendar about when it's
actually due
right now there's a limit to how well
that works because
obviously i know that it's a possibility
but the basic point is look i know
she's not going to use this to her
advantage and my disadvantage
so she's not making money the more she
lies to you right she's still using it
for your best interest and there's
actually a
shared partnership of you know even your
own children that creates skin in the
game so that relationship is grounded in
a real sort of
you know sense yeah the uh the term we
use for it is shared fate
right sure because we have shared fate
the point is you're gonna if you're
gonna lie to me you're gonna do it
honorably right
and there's obviously ways in which that
you know she
started up with some guy and started
lying to me that wouldn't be it would be
the exact opposite but
um in the absence of such a thing she
has license to figure out where the line
is and even if we slightly disagree
over it uh it's done uh
with good intentions and i should say
this is now uncomfortable
but i also find that my relationship
with my
children involves um
a huge amount of
my gaming their perceptual apparatus my
kids
are you know 16 and 14 at this point but
this has been true
all along and it is always done
in the context of humor
but the basic point is some part of me
knows that they
live in a world in which they're going
to be confronted with [ __ ]
right every waking hour right there's
going to be
advertisements con men algorithms all
sorts of stuff
and so i use
my the the license that comes with humor
to misportray things so that they will
get really good at detecting
falseness right and um
i mean i know it works and they know
i'm not doing it for my benefit and
against theirs and so
you know it's rather like the example of
uh your spouse having
license and in this case it's even
tighter because you know you can lose a
spouse but your kids are your kids
forever
um so the question then is what is the
basis
on which departures you know in effect
the
honorable um shortcutting
or white lies that exist in the context
of family are effectively
a heuristic right for family
well-being in the same way that your
perceptual apparatus makes jumps
uh in order for you to process things in
real time
so the the question is is there a basis
of trust and this is a long way of
saying
the thing we can very clearly see when a
for-profit
corporation is engaged in finding your
perceptual defects and exploiting them
is that a transfer of wealth is directly
possible
right you have the ability to decide
where to spend your money and where to
spend your time
and they have an interest that departs
from yours
and so they can effectively take time or
direct wealth or whatever it is in some
direction that you wouldn't have it go
to your detriment and they can come out
ahead by doing it and i think
you know the the ultimate upshot of this
is if they do that
that it actually deranges us
collectively
something they didn't anticipate right
the
the the uh side effect
is potentially fatal to humanity correct
because i think we we often focus too
much in my work
especially when people reference time
well spent started in this way and
people thought the only critique here
was addiction or the harm was
depression or isolation or one of these
individual harms but really
the emphasis on the in the long run is
this sort of collective derangement
which is
if you think about you know this is a
business model that you know privately
profits
but then collectively harms meaning it
puts harms on the balance sheets of
society and
pollutes their balance sheet you know in
the balance sheet of society is a
inability to see
a shared reality have a different notion
of history of what's happened
or what's fair what's equal because
we've each seen different
levels literally infinite evidence of
the other side lying or
being hypocritical and it creates no
room for um
shared growth i wanted to bring back um
i know that your previous metaphor that
i've loved about this is the notion of
metaphorical truth versus a real truth
and the porcupine story the idea that
porcupines shoot their quills
um i just thought this was so important
in in bringing it out because this is a
deception
but a deception that is in the greater
benefit now the question is who do you
trust to construct that because you
could have
tribes that let's say have false wisdom
that are creating false deceptions
uh false stories that are shortcuts and
heuristics and then there's also a
developmental aspect here where
maybe when you're young i can say poor
you know porcupines shoot their quills
and so
please stay away from porcupines but
when you're older you've outgrown
that that metaphorical fiction maybe i
need a new one i'll tell you the truth
right so maybe
you know when you're young i'll tell you
about santa claus when you're older i'll
tell you
you know there's there's a developmental
new place to land uh these are all
interesting philosophical
i think areas of asymmetric persuasive
relationships where we have
you know more more ability to influence
people but i also think i want to say
it's not just psychological or
perceptual vulnerabilities we're talking
about here there's also identity level
vulnerabilities and that's where this
gets really insane i mean in the film
the social dilemma we talk about
how if i'm you know a foreign adversary
of the united states
um and i want people to not think this
is not some partisan just russia thing
or china there's lots of countries that
are now doing this
i can go into a conspiracy theory group
like a cuban like a pizzagate or
whatever
and i can actually get the user ids of
people
that are that are of that mindset then i
can pump them into a facebook look-alike
model
and say give me users who have the same
kind of profile like that
so facebook is giving me it's not just
that facebook was doing gain of function
research on
mimetics or on groups or extremism it's
that they're actually offering data
function it's gain of function as a
service
they're offering that to other parties
to actually get
more and more clever at being able to
find and navigate and then
and then further there split test which
messages would work
for those audiences and one of the
things that we know and again i want to
be really careful because
we can steal man and and uh there's a
pre-trans fallacy on what a conspiracy
is and there's this sort of you know
using it to deride people who think
versus the actual genuine
real conspiracies that are that are that
are true um
but i think this is really important
because uh
one of the other things we know about
conspiracy thinking is the best
predictor of whether you'll believe in
another conspiracy is whether you
already believe in one because it starts
to warp
the basis of your perception the kind of
trust that you have like if it was true
that the entire government
was lying about covet and it actually
did come from the u.s it
i mean which who who knows where it came
from and that's topic of conversation
but if it were intentional in that way
that would certainly
warp the perceptions downstream of
everything else because if that were
true then all these other things were
true
now we're getting we're getting into i
don't want to go too deep into you know
one of these specific ones or not
because i want to stay on the kind of
identity hacking but i wanted to make
sure we were clear
that the level of psychological and
evolutionary hacking
is memetic it's perceptual it is social
validation based
it is social relationship based it's
also identity based in fact in
facebook's own documents in 2000
i think nine or ten that it was they had
a facebook marketing team in australia
that said
we literally know when a child when it
when a user has low self-esteem they're
talking about teenagers
they literally can predict based on
usage patterns when you are low
self-esteem and that's an identity level
manipulation which is very much like
cults
cults actually catch people in moments
of vulnerability what we know from cult
recruiting
is that they're actually in between huge
moments of transition something in their
life a meaning making structure has
collapsed whether it's
a relationship or a job or a deceased
loved one or
divorce and they're in that moment of
low self-esteem and kind of low meaning
and that's exactly what makes them more
vulnerable
we've enabled and sam harris and i
talked about this on his podcast
is a kind of cult factory where there is
a mass
finding of people in vulnerable states
and then being able to personally target
to a whole new degree again with this
sort of gain of function metaphor
uh what what we could do to steer them
and the idea that this is the default
infrastructure
that runs our digital economy that this
would allow that we would allow for and
even make money from the gain of
functionalization of everything
is incredibly dangerous and we i just
want to drive people there because i
want people to see
just how deeply the reform is you know
needs to be um
yeah marvelous um so i do want to
briefly touch on this issue of
conspiracy predicting whether or not you
know the belief in a single conspiracy
results in a change in your likelihood
of uh or at least it predicts that you
will believe in a second one
that actually this is about a heuristic
being built
right to the extent that something
persuades you that collusion has taken
place in a given
circumstance it naturally adjusts your
sense of how common
collusion is and corrosively
it adjusts your sense of how to weight
evidence because if there's one thing
that's common to all conspiracies
it is that they portray some other
possibility as more likely they
inherently
frame some alternative so basically what
it does is it forces you to sideline
your obligation to occam's razor
and there are cases where a little bit
of side lining of occam's razor is
absolutely necessary to make progress
but it's also the kind of thing that if
you give up on it you just become a
sucker
right that's right so it's very hard to
navigate that space
and basically by pumping noise in
we are breaking people's relationship to
reality and evidence
very directly um and the consequences
is all but inevitable i would say right
of course people will just become so
distrustful that they will
effectively become full-time
superstitious that's right and that's
kind of where we are is what it feels
like right i mean
and the challenges you said is there are
ways of navigating the beyond occam's
razor explanation for something
um and you're doing that a lot here on
your program and i i think that's you
know really fantastic but people need
the tools to do that
carefully because because there that
process can externalize
a kind of naive distrust uh or a kind of
naive epistemic process that starts to
as you said kind of get
further and further superstitious if you
don't have the tools and i think much
like
i always use a developmental paradigm
when i think about these things you know
you
at certain ages we we we speak in some
ways it's other ages we speak in other
ways we tell you about santa clauses
in our friend daniel barcay's point that
you know um he said life is a lifelong
process
of killing santa claus like your sort of
top one santa claus metaphorical story
the porcupine thing the simplistic story
that suits you for a period it's a
growth you know it's a jacket you can
wear for that period but then you
outgrow it and there's a different
developmental paradigm so maybe
you know if we're going to engage in
non-outcomes razor narratives and really
do investigations we have to be aware of
developmentally which minds we're
speaking to
am i talking to someone who's literally
kind of a basement conspiracy theorist
with like a bunch of guns in their
closet and they're ready to go take arms
to something
consequently i have to be more worried
about the way that my communication
might impact that person
than if i'm talking to you know someone
uh
who's really thoughtfully engaging with
alternative narratives and epistemology
and actually has a whole process that
they've developed
to navigate that and i think that's one
of the things that we lose especially in
a social media landscape when you're
broadcasting to
you know 10 million people at once we
don't have a developmentally sensitive
communication meaning our communication
is going to so many people that we
assume
and this is probably the wise critique
of engaging in any kind of alternate
narrative thinking
is hey you know you eric and you brett
are not sufficiently engaging with
um how people might hear you
consequentially but then you're saying
yeah but you don't see that we're
ignoring really important truths that we
don't get to talk about we're going to
get trapped by political correctness so
we're going to get trapped by
you know these other things and this is
where i think it gets very very
interesting
yeah and actually um this is another
uncomfortable
topic which is that i know
i am capable of calculating that some of
the places where i
question the official narrative
it is essentially certain that people
are going to get
hurt as a result of my revealing that
these things are questionable so for
example if we talk about what we don't
know about vaccine safety
with respect to the the novel uh coveted
vaccines
it is essentially inevitable given the
size of the audience that a certain
number of people will change their
view on whether to get the vaccine some
of them will get coveted some of them
may die the
other people may catch covet from them
who will die that's a terrible
responsibility
i don't want it no rational person could
want it but
what i believe is that our sense-making
around these things
is so broken that we are already killing
people as a result of
our obligation to sign up for these
official narratives that aren't true and
so
i guess you know it's hard to know what
the right analogy
is but the mechanism that you
uh have been exploring through which
attention is captured
and uh sense making is deranged
that mechanism is like somebody has been
working on a you know a computer or
some sort of robotic device that you can
put in the driver's seat of your car
and it can pilot you right now i don't
doubt that you can make a self-driving
car we all know that's coming
sooner or later but if you tell me that
you've built this in your garage
and you're going to put it in the
driver's seat of the car and we're going
to go somewhere
we're going to crash this is a prototype
right and the nature of prototypes is
that you're going to discover
all of the hazards you didn't know about
along the way and you really want to
discover that on a closed track you
don't want to discover that
with civilization in tow right and
that's where we are is we are running
the biggest experiment that has ever
been run in real time with
all of us on board there's not some
population living somewhere who isn't
downstream of the effects of this even
if you're offline
right we're all in totally it's uh
you know you and others have said it's
the largest unregulated psychology
experiment we've ever run with no irb
board if you want to use the zuckerberg
institute of virology metaphor and you
have level what is it called the level
five sort of
yeah yeah right level four so if you
have kind of the level four
you know societal engineering lab but
you're literally not even
doing it in the big white suits and in
the kind of enclosed spaces you're just
doing it on civilization
constantly you're in this sort of 24 7.
and we're actually still there right
it's not as if right now there are not
three billion people
who just jacked into facebook twitter
youtube etc
who are now in the live sort of you know
memetic
um tweaking of where these things are
going and so now the virus is sort of
out of control we're doing live tweaking
to try to steer it i think
at this point by the way i want to say i
often am perceived as sort of a
i don't know a critic of the the system
or making people evil i don't believe
any of these people are evil i think
they have
not seen the consequences of the process
that they were in the race to the bottom
of the brainstem
evolutionary landscape that they were
competing within but the problem is now
they don't have
you know even the tools the the levers
to actually
do the gain of function for the sort of
the the tweaking back
towards some kind of stabilizing force
and that's i think the predicament that
we're really in and frankly this is the
open inquiry i'm in is
i think we obviously need tweaking of
the technology and and to fix it at that
level because that's the thing that
we're continually jacked into
but i also think we need almost like you
know once the pandemic
of covet is out there we you know we do
need some kind of protection mechanism
to to
you know isolate the virus i think we
need a cultural antibody we need a
cultural awareness we need a cultural i
don't want to say vaccine because that
itself is polarizing
but we need some kind of common
understanding and the thing that i don't
want to speak too highly of the film's
impact
for the for the social dilemma but i
think one thing it does do since about
100 million people have seen it is it
creates a new shared
common ground about at least one very
primary explanation about how we lost
common ground to this degree
so to have shared common ground about
where and how we've lost common ground
is at least a place to stand from so
that we can then say how do we want to
proceed back into more common ground
um and i and i think that's kind of a
you know an open inquiry that i'm in is
what is what does that look like
all right two things one we are in if we
go back to the earlier part of our
conversation about
shared fate and what it allows you to
assume is true
the irony here is that we have shared
fate right this is a tiny
planet our industrial processes
are at a scale now that we are our own
biggest hazard
and so our fate is tied and to the
extent that our
sense making is deranged because in the
moment one group can get financially
ahead of another
by doing things that derange us in the
long
run we may all perish together as a
result of the process having not
realized having not
had it built into us that our fate is
shared and we should treat it carefully
the way you would treat
your spouse for example but i also think
there's a way in which
even the dire picture that you just
painted
doesn't fully describe the hazard
because
let's say that there was one let's say
that there was only google
right if only google was involved in
deranging us
then google stands a chance
of figuring out the hazard and
correcting things right
backing us away from the precipice but
the problem is let's say that google
figured out that they were a hazard and
realized they they repented right and
they
you know invested a huge amount in
figuring out how to underrange us
but facebook and twitter and instagram
and all the
other forces weren't on board with the
program
right it's a little like imagining we're
hurtling through an asteroid field
right and you've got six people in six
different control rooms
trying to adjust the cameras that allow
us to see
where the asteroids are and so as one
person
adjusts a dial that makes the image
better somebody else may adjust a dial
to put it back the way it was because
they were
trying some other correction right all
of these disconnected things
are basically an amplifier for noise
right at best at best so
um now the question really
let's say that something like that is
going on the question really is
what conceivable solutions exist here
do you know i mean this is our daily
work at the center for humane technology
and just on a daily basis just among
peers i mean i i feel the the the first
point you're making
about shared fate is is exactly where
we've just been the
the whole time it's just we we're all in
this thing together right because i
think
to the earlier point we were making
about we're all addicted our amygdalas
are all available for mining and hacking
uh whether we know it or not even if
you're aware of the amygdala mining it
still works if you show me something
that makes me angry
i will get angry i can try to be mindful
of it but again
the asymmetry of influence and the
infinite feeds of the outrage are more
powerful than my
sort of daily mindfulness practice and
we shouldn't put that burden on
individual minds anyway
to have to develop the superstructure or
i think your brother calls it the
metacognitive perch
upon which to not be so hijacked by
whether it's narrative control or
amygdala control
um yeah i mean when it comes to
i i think we have to see some kind of
shared fate i mean when you when you ask
it that way
something i've been pondering recently
and you know this history better than i
do because you were around when this
happened
and i was just born a year later is in
1983
the film the day after uh comes to mind
um i i became obsessed when i my my
whole life with sort of the history of
nuclear weapons and how close we got and
um how in the world after we invented
the technology to destroy ourselves i
mean there's all these nuclear
scientists who were convinced seeing
this exponential power
that they actually committed suicide i
mean there's i think the story of is it
feynman or
one of the scientists who was in the
back of a taxi looking out at
you know the bridges of new york city
and just thought like what's the point
why are they building these bridges
when it's we already screwed it up right
it's over it's over we built the nuclear
weapons it's
you know and they actually committed
suicide thinking that was the end of the
whole thing
and i think um you know it's kind of
remarkable because if you lived in that
period you probably would think
um as i felt and if i was there
that it that it was over and the
interesting thing for those who don't
know
this film the day after was the largest
prime time tv event in american history
i think it was a tuesday or wednesday
night it aired at 7 pm
um on television it was a film um made
by the director
um i forgot his name actually but
we'll look it up later and it's about a
hypothetical nuclear exchange between
the us
and russia a full-scale nuclear exchange
i'm told through
you know narrative of regular people
living in kansas and a couple of montana
and a couple other places where the you
know
the missiles are underground etc and
you know airing this on prime time
television and having
essentially the whole psyche of the
entire country and it was aired around
the world
essentially see the shared fate because
we can't you know if the shared fate
happens it's too late so we have to
actually
simulate the shared fate put it into the
collective psyches of everyone so that
the omni lose-lose outcome
becomes visible to every actor realizing
that the escalation doesn't work
and um this film was later credited
with shifting ronald reagan's personal
psychology because he saw the film and
sent him
chills it gave him chills it led to him
at wanting to do the star wars project
which was a failed project but at least
it
led him away from the idea that we could
win a nuclear war
and what's interesting about this film
is it was aired in primetime tv 100
million americans saw it largest tv
event in history in the u.s
then they had a panel um afterwards i
don't know if you remember this but they
actually had a panel
of henry kissinger um william f buckley
junior carl sagan brent scowcroft
you know the sort of the best military
minds of the generation having a public
discussion with the american public
reckoning with hey hey guys we actually
have had the power to destroy ourselves
we all just saw it
now we're actually having the
uncomfortable conversation we can't be
in denial about it anymore what are we
going to do about this
and you know i just think that kind of
film that kind of initiative that kind
of shared fate
visualization stuffing that into the
minds of everyone
is the kind of thing that we need to
ground the much more extreme
action we need to take that this will
not work unless we take
some action together that this is a
shared fate that's beautiful
but um there's a problem with it i mean
i
certainly remember the day after and
uh you know basically someone decided to
traumatize us all
together i assume their motives were
good but the effect i think was
certainly positive
as you point out the problem is
that in the case of nuclear weapons and
an all-out exchange
the likelihood of coming out ahead
is pretty small right and so
it is a much easier problem to solve by
revealing its nature
because in general the mindset that you
have to you know
you basically get into um
dr strangelove territory where
you know the crazies are
interested in you know winning the
post-apocalypse
right right so very few of us are on
board with that
and so it's much easier to say hey
actually this nuclear weapon thing
is a special kind of predicament that
requires a new kind of cognition in
order to even understand how to
calibrate and of course there's a lot to
be said here
uh one thing that's true is
it's in some ways an unsolvable problem
until you have global agreement to get
rid of the weapons because
sooner or later they will be used by
accident or some other
mechanism so it's we have temporarily
solved the problem
right on a time scale that many of those
who saw the invention of these weapons
did not expect
it is also quite possible and in fact
likely
that the weapons themselves prevented a
lot of
other warfare correct yep right and so
anyway it's a concept that has a full
accounting
completely right there with you right um
but the other thing i would say
is that the difference between the
nuclear weapon situation
and the derangement of civilization
via feed and search algorithms etc
is it goes back to the question of magic
the fact that you know that the magician
is fooling you does not allow you to see
in what way you are being fooled
and this is you know the problem is
there's no winner
in the nuclear exchange there is very
definitely a winner
short term in the the derangement
problem
and so we need some sort of
i mean i think i think the point is in
some ways um
you know the social dilemma is the day
after
for derangement and yet
as much as a lot of us saw it
understood the message agree on it
i don't know how much farther ahead we
are on the puzzle completely well i
think
this is this is critical but i'm so glad
we're talking about this step by step
because i've
where i'm lost frankly where i don't
have an answer is the outcome of the day
after was
if you think about it from a theory of
change it influenced
one person i mean a set of leaders
especially ronald reagan
to shift policy and then there was a
shift in what could happen because those
were people in control of
a centralized exponential technology
that could destroy everything
into the shared fate in this case um
i guess you could say we have a small
set of technology leaders so those could
be the
you know the five ronald reagans
governing the five nuclear-armed
intersubjective i think of
the narrative derangement syndrome you
know
technology infrastructure we have as
kind of nuclear weapons for the inner
subjective world so
nuclear weapons were for the outer
environment but
facebook and twitter and youtube etc
again i want to basic i also would like
to make sure that your audience hears me
acknowledge that i'm very aware of the
incredible benefits that these things
provide too and i just want to say
blood donors finding each other high
school sweethearts finding each other
youtube producing lots of learning
opportunities music videos pumping
people up with exciting you know
courageous you know ways of waking up in
the morning
um i see all that the challenges on the
inner subjective side
going nuclear on a shared reality is a
unsurvivable outcome if you can't
recover from it so there's two kinds of
harm there's reversible harm where you
cause the harm
cause a you know maybe a disease in the
body and there's there's some kind of
medical way to reverse it or to
rebalance your system symbiotically by
you know whatever that's great but then
the irreversible harm the kind of i
think
losing trust for example in sense making
losing trust overall not trusting any
institution not trusting each other
is a very hard place to recover from
that's in the more irreversible harm
category
so what i worry about is that when you
when you go nuke the inner subjective
realm especially at the trust layer
not just the inner the informational
layer um that's
that's a place that i don't know how you
recover from now again to your point
who would you convince so we have these
kind of five ronald reagan type
figures who who are in control of the
tech platforms but they're
governed not just you know reagan could
theoretically make the decision
himself and yes he had a country to
report to but he was now influenced by
that country
in this case we have five ronald reagan
tech platform ceos
i'm just throwing the number five around
there's lots of different tech platforms
but let's just use that
they report to their shareholders
they're publicly traded companies that
actually can't get off
this boat so they're trapped just like
we are you know and
um your brother eric has this great line
that you know
listening to tech company ceos talk is
sometimes like watching a hostage in a
hostage video
you ever see a hostage in hostage video
and it's like they're saying things that
don't really add up you're like why are
they saying this gibberish that doesn't
make any sense
until you see off stage there's someone
holding a gun to their head
and the gun to their head is their
business model and it's their their
share price
that has to keep going up and so that's
i think you know the kind of situation
uh that we're in that we're in there
okay
two things one i want to put an asterisk
around this question of shareholders
because i'm less and less convinced that
it's playing the role we think it's
playing
i know that it should and i don't know
why it's not but i think we can see
evidence that something else is afoot
and it may be somebody off stage with a
gun to the head but
i don't think it's the shareholders at
this point but
um let's talk about the question
of your analogy to a disease
and the ability to restore the body to
health yeah
the problem is analogous almost
to half a bone marrow transplant
right so you've got an immune system
that's out of control you've got
leukemia or something
right and the way to solve it
is to get rid of the immune system which
would be fatal in and of itself if you
didn't replace it with another one you
got to replace it and it has to take
right but if you just go halfway the
point is okay you've just killed the
patient
they were going to die of leukemia and
now you've killed them on a much shorter
time scale
and in effect the problem here is that
the
destruction of
here we've got a problem you know
there's this this old
ironic line you know who you're going to
believe me or your own eyes
what we've got is you know the irony of
who you're going to believe me or your
own eyes is that obviously the answer is
i'm going to believe my own eyes
right okay but the problem is if
somebody is gaming
your visual apparatus such that your
eyes are not reporting
accurately then the answer is actually
you know i'm gonna believe the mission
the magician when they tell me what they
did rather than what i saw
right in that case i have to make an
exception here what we've got
is a cyborg
that is a fusion between
intelligent creative human beings and
unintelligent
ai-like stuff learning to
disrupt our own ability to manage our
time
and to understand how to evaluate
claims that we are seeing and
ultimately a smart person who is not in
a position to control
this phenomenon and no none of us are
ends up distrustful of their own eyes
and everything else and the point is
you cannot just go back because once
you've learned
that your own eyes are lying to you
right that your own
instincts about what's true and false
are unreliable
how does something use those instincts
to inform you okay we've now
restored sense making or sense making is
getting better
right the point is once you've turned
off the input because you just don't
trust it
you are now that much harder to cure and
it's very much like
having had your bone marrow nuked with
radiation and then
uh nobody bothered to infuse you with a
new
immune system um so anyway i'm concerned
that this is
that there's an asymmetry here where the
damage is all too easy to do
with this level of technology and the
process of undoing it is
you know a hundred times harder well by
the way this is this is actually why
um there's no kind of uh kind of told
you so phenomenon behind the words i'm
saying now but
there's a you know so much of what was
so hard looking at this three
three years ago um i remember walking
into senators offices talking about this
and just feeling like oh my god
there's no adults in the room there's so
few people who get that this process is
happening
um the more people who fall into these
narrower
you know more extreme views of reality
is a hard process to reverse once you go
there
and we have self-reinforcing feedback
loops the gain of function
process that is continuing to make this
happen this is going to be so bad in
three or four years
and and here we are and i say that again
not there's no
you know this is just why it was so
important to try to stop it earlier
because
once you get here it's very very hard
now there are epistemic processes
to you know do more grounded sense
making you can
recover i mean i i you know my one of my
favorite
teachers byron katie has sort of a
semi-new age spiritual teacher but she
has a a wonderful simple process you can
use to just question your beliefs it
comes down to four questions for
anything you're
holding in your mind that that gives you
stress you just ask it's very similar to
cognitive behavioral therapy
you ask is it true can i be
absolutely sure that it is true so
you're destabilizing the full grip of
whatever belief that it is because no
belief can fully represent 100 of the
time
reality or very few can then the third
question is um
how do i react what happens when i
believe this thought when i believe this
belief
and the fourth question is who would i
be not what would happen
like behaviorally but who would i be
identity level question
without this thought and you can start
to kind of do culti programming on
yourself but deprogramming yourself from
the cult of your own
lifelong process of tribalism identity
experiences etc and we can all be part
of a culture that was trying to
deprogram ourselves from the shared
cults
or you know fractal cults that we've all
been part of in this cult factory
process
but as you said we don't really have a
lot of time here um and so
that's where i just jumped to okay what
can we agree on that are our problems
that we have limited time on and we try
to figure out
what will actually be sufficient there
um and i know you know people like our
mutual friend daniel schmuckenberger are
people i trust to be doing that kind of
process to be thinking about
um these various existential threats and
um societal problems and what
you know what how could we get agreement
on these things more quickly
it's very hard you know this is this is
you could sort of say game over
uh where where we are right now but i i
prefer to say
instead what what would it take what
would be most helpful
um uh to align ourselves back on that
track and how can we align our actions
on a daily basis
you know towards that that kind of world
so you know i find myself in a very
parallel situation and in fact it may be
two facets of the same gem right so as
you were
trying to raise the alarm about the
derangement of civilization and finding
no
adults in the room as you know i was
watching my college
go insane and recognizing that it was
actually a manifestation of a thought
pattern that was
sure to spill out into the world and
start deranging us
at a much larger level and of course the
two things certainly interact
right um and there is this very
frustrating
feeling of you know i try never to say i
told you so
right it's hollow and pointless on the
other hand
i think what i want people to get from
someone in your position or my position
is look
i clearly did know what was coming right
that could be a fluke
but it probably isn't because you can
look up at what i said about why i
thought it was coming
right and you can see that the thought
process was right
in light of that the fact that i am
currently alarmed about where we're
headed
that i believe that the problem is
dire that as hard as it is to solve
today
it only gets harder right those are
things which should have
our near complete attention because of
what is at stake and
we do not need to know the details of
what will go down it doesn't matter it's
like not knowing
how the robot that you've just put in
the driver's seat of the car is going to
crash it
right but you're going to find out and
so anyway
you know i have little things that i say
to myself
and others if they want to hear them one
is
it's very late but it's not too late
the point is any part of you that says
oh my god how are we going to solve this
it's
hopeless the answer is well if you think
it's hopeless now
try ignoring it another two years right
so
getting people motivated to confront
this now and really you know your point
about ronald reagan
uh it's a complex point but let's just
say superficially
the point was there was a ronald reagan
and he could be persuaded by
a narrative and it could affect policy
and unfortunately
you know five major tech platforms
governed by uh people who frankly don't
have the right
kind of expertise to even navigate the
hazard
right they know their business very well
but they don't know
how the rest of civilization functions
very well
that this is this is urgent and what we
really need
is human discretion
right there has to be somebody with veto
power
over the tech platform's ability to try
any new experiment in order to do
what they see as their job right there's
too much at stake no matter what else is
true they are putting us all in jeopardy
it's not their right
and it's obviously a dangerous and
foolish experiment
you're hitting on such great points here
because then then we get to some of the
areas that you're closer to
which is what does it mean for tech
platforms to be governing
all of civilization and doing so not in
an autocratic way and i know you've been
the victim of
um you know sort of autocratic shutdowns
um uh
in your own right and moreover you said
you know
let's take apple for example because
i've actually used the metaphor that
apple is kind of like the central bank
or
federal reserve of the attention economy
and
they actually have the ability to do
quantitative easing or to maybe this is
not the right metaphor because people
are against quantitative easing
for reasons i understand but they have
the ability to sort of tweak
the rules incentive guardrails irb
standards if you will of the attention
economy
apple could say hey we actually just
don't allow this kind of psychological
experimentation you could do sandboxing
you can do proofs about what you think
is going to help or not
we're going to name make a list of what
we currently deem to be just unsafe
levels of
harm or derangement that is occurring
from certain platforms
now again what i'm describing you could
say is what led to apple
taking down parlor and doing that
autocratically and on their terms of
hey you don't have enough content
moderators well ironically due to the
cultural derangement syndrome people saw
that
in multiple different ways depending on
which part of the reality derangement
you know fractal you were you were
inside of so if you were on the right
you saw that as part of a left power
grab and a left oriented
you know political pow you know power
within apple and amazon etc
being politically motivated to
de-platform a right-leaning
technology product if you were
on the left you saw it as something
different if you were
trying to see it neutrally and assuming
that it is not politically motivated
you could say that they actually didn't
have the kind of moderation to deal with
actual brewing problems that that they
were not doing so again what would make
apple trustworthy
in setting up some kind of irb process
or in some kind of some kind of
democratic council for
all of these issues and as you said the
people who run apple you know tim cook
um uh phil schiller uh craig
uh i forgot his last name uh who runs
all of product at apple
these are people with expertise in
business with
technology these are not people who have
expertise in civilization design
or essentially brain implants for 3
billion people
or a brain implant for the collective
psyche of humanity
which is essentially the expertise they
need to be in to make the decisions that
are
protective of humanity at this level but
i want to point to this because it's
actually an area of success um just
recently about a week ago tim cook gave
a speech
in fact he said in that speech we cannot
allow a social dilemma
to become a social catastrophe and he
was referencing the social dilemma in
in reference to set of changes that
apple was making
to go after app targeting uh business
models the ability for apps to track you
across different applications
in other words sort of taking down the
advertising business model in its micro
targeted form
and moving back to kind of a 1960s 70s
era
billboard advertising contextual
advertising topical advertising but not
micro targeting so this is apple
essentially saying hey we have this
whole ecosystem
and we're going to nudge the ecosystem
away from some of the toxic components
of the attention economy
towards a less personalized not
micro-targeted form
of the attention economy now this is a
very small change but it deeply has
affected
many of especially the kind of facebook
and google parts of the world which
they're very
not happy about and claiming anti-trust
sort of motivate you know
actions against against apple and taking
this unilateral action but i think we
can zoom out and say okay
there's two ways to fail here one is um
you know autocratic tech ceos wake up
and just make
you know instant reactionary decisions
based on the impulses of a present
moment
uh and that's bad but the other way to
fail is to not make decisions about
things that are actual threats so we
don't want to not make a decision and
allow the frankenstein
to keep eating up the world and
deranging the world but we also don't
want autocratic decisions where
some algorithm gets produced and
suddenly brett weinstein is off of
twitter and facebook and there's no
appeal process and
you happen to you know hear the person
from facebook get back to you later
compared to the thousands of people who
would have no appeal process
so what we need is some kind of you know
there needs it needs to be in
a governance of humanity like
essentially some kind of democratic
governance with the expertise of what it
means to be a brain implant for the
collective psyche
of humanity apple's in a very unique
position because it governs the app
store
and google because it governs the play
store on android
to try to steer things in that direction
some people are going to like the sound
of that because they don't like the
power that
that what that means but i think we have
to say it's we have to have some
governance process
yeah it's both hopeful because you point
out that the power
exists there and hopeless i mean even
just the
idea that we have to prevent this from
becoming
a what did you say derangement
catastrophe
that idea is i don't know
six seven years too late we're already
there
right it's the choice between a crash
and a crash landing it's not a hard
landing at this point right we
we've got a serious problem and nobody
knows how to turn the ship around and so
it's a little bit like
you know the captain of the titanic
beginning to grapple with the hazard of
you know a iceberg as
they show up on the horizon it's like
well it's the goddamn titanic
right it's not going to turn on a dime
you need to wake up faster right and
there's also the point that okay
apple finds itself in the position that
you describe
it doesn't deserve the position you
describe
it doesn't have even the superficial
characteristics
that you would imagine would allow it to
navigate that position
well in other words okay what is it
that's supposed to
tell to inform apple of the way in which
it is supposed to
steer things away from dangerous
derangement phenomena
is it shareholders they are obligated to
maximize shareholder
value which i already told you i suspect
is not
playing the role we think because we see
corporations now routinely making
decisions that are nakedly political
about who they don't want on their
platform even though it's hard to
imagine
how that enhances their their bottom
line right you would expect
a kind of indifference about content in
order to get everybody on the platform
and
not create a market of a competitor for
a competitor to
you know leap up and serve customers
who've been thrown off the platform
you would expect a lot of things that
we're not seeing so what is that is that
shareholders deciding that they value
something above
financial return possibly in which case
this is
novel territory i would say maybe i'm
missing something
but the idea is you know what
apple can't do it you're right global
processes
need global governance and of course
this freaks people out
but my point is not we need global
governance my point is
global processes need global governance
right the alternative to a governed
a well-governed global process is an
ungoverned global process and that is a
disaster
so that's where we are now right and
without taking any actions we're in that
dystopia if we take actions we're in
autocratic
1984 dystopias we need something that is
actual global governance and you know
and you're right to say you know it's
not like
we would have wanted to be in this
situation where this particular set of
human beings ends up at the top of this
decision-making hierarchy
because they had the expertise no they
got there because they were good at
building
attention-grabbing tech products or the
hardware software you know 40-year
trajectory of apple
um but you know how we how we navigate
from there what that looks like i mean
what
you know i justin rosenstein who's in
the film um and uh
has a new book out called the new
possible i wrote an essay for it and
it's
it's actually about visions of the
possible from
where you know across the sort of
economic landscape where we see these
systemic problems and one of the things
that's brought up a lot is sort of the
citizen council or citizen juries
to actually if you know that james fish
can work on deliberative democracy
bring groups of citizens into a process
where they actually
hear all the evidence from experts and
they're actually there's it
it's proven to lead to actually pretty
even dramatic changes in people's
understandings and beliefs and actions
about what they would want to happen
um in ireland for example there was a
whole thing a referendum i think on gay
marriage and it
led people who had even been against
that in the beginning to
through you know a two or three day
process lead to actually voting i think
for
uh legalizing i think gay marriage um
and we could have processes like that
but again
as you said we have this sort of global
we have a global thing
so we do that in english you know how
many courts do we need how many juries
do we need
you know one of the things i know i was
planning to
be ready to talk about is with your
situation with getting de-platformed
without any kind of review
you know we need appeals processes and
courts but if you think about the scale
of accounts the scale of messages that
are needing to be adjudicated
we don't have juries and courts for
enough of the people messages etc that
are going to be flagged
we're generating more you know
discrimination or cases than we have the
ability to have courts to
to govern um and and i think this is
actually a fundamental paradox in
technology because the benefit
of technology is automation and scale
the fact that you have
fewer human being decision makers and
you get more leverage through these
automated processes but when
a human judgment situation comes up we
need to have as many courtrooms and
lawyers and judges and juries
as we have issues that we need to be
adjudicated and if we
have things that are consequential
enough to cause irreparable harm
faster than the court case date comes up
where your case can be heard
you know you don't want to wait you know
a year two years five years until
you get to decide whether you get to
come back to facebook or twitter we
don't want to
have apple wait years to make decisions
about
you know the derangement syndromes and
the irb standards that they would try to
put to you know enclose these these
perverse frankensteins
um i think we need a ranked priority
list though of how we deal with these
issues and protect against all the forms
of tyranny and dystopia that we want and
you know you've many times pointed out
the sort of orwellian
tyranny that that you are that you were
the victim of and i think the other
tyranny we've been talking about for
much of this
conversation so far has been the huxley
in tyranny the huxley and dystopia
where it is not and this is stolen from
neil postman's book i'm using ourselves
to death
but we always worried about 1984 and the
ability to ban books and censure
information and censorship
but then we didn't worry about this
other world where we give people so much
information that no one
actually reads books no one actually has
the attention spans everyone is sort of
stuck in their pleasure machine
in their affirmation machine their soma
machine that they don't have
a legitimate society and so i think if
we make some lists of here's the
dystopias that we're
either in or we don't want to fall into
here's the ranking of those problems
what are the things that need to happen
at a global governance level to do it
you know this does look pretty bleak i
mean let's be honest about where we are
uh you know i you and i have talked in
the past about
how hard it is psychologically to
wrestle with staring these things face
to face
on a daily basis and i think that's
actually part of this is psychologically
how can you look at some of these things
but
i think that's where we are and we have
to ask what would help from that point
and i'm curious if you see things
differently or
no i mean i think you know you and i
have a difference in the way
we look at this i think
we both see a bleak picture and
i think there's an emotional difference
in how we react to it
but there's not a substantive difference
i think
the the number of dystopias that we can
allow us
ourselves to fall into is zero right
we agree that there are many and they're
therefore tensions between solutions but
i want to divide two things because you
talk about
the need for you know in a vast
court system in order to address all of
the potential claims of an infraction
etc
that's one way to do it the other way to
do it is to separate
the question of um
the derangement that arises through uh
algorithmic competition
from the question of speech
entirely right in other words
i don't know of an effort to not
sell pens ink
paper any of these things to people
with a political perspective in other
words i think we have swallowed the idea
that actually we're not going to prevent
nazis from rising by denying them paper
right it's not a good bet right the
world you have to build
to keep nazis from getting paper but
allow everybody else to have it
is not a tolerable world so the point is
okay the ship has sailed they're going
to have paper that's not we have to
fight them
on the landscape of ideas not the
landscape of uh
writing implements and the question is
what is the online environment
well it's two things it's a bunch of
businesses battling and putting us in
the danger
that you're talking about and it is also
the public square
whether you like it or not and so at the
level of the public square i want to
know
very clearly what the limits are of what
can be said
and i do not want people policed for
even obnoxious points of view right
obnoxious points of view are going to
have to be tolerated and
we have to trust in the fact that um
given
complete freedom to talk the obnoxious
points of view
are driven out bigotry declines right
that's
been the nature of it and trying to
police bigotry
is a recipe to create exactly the
opposite phenomenon
so so anyway let's separate that out and
let's say
the way to deal with the unimaginably
large number of courts that we would
have to create to police every
infraction is to say actually the
infractions are going to be fairly clear
and few in number
because what you're going to be allowed
to say online is going to be
the same thing you would be allowed to
say standing on a street corner
right and then we can separate off the
issue that's really a hazard to us
which is so we create a hazard if we try
to police speech online
right there's no conceivable system that
could do that well
and the dystopias that arise from bad
attempts to do it are
several but then we've got the other
dystopia which is the evolutionary
novelty dystopia
where something decides to borrow you
know something decides to play a
magician
and it begins to evolve and before you
know it
nobody even knows how it works much less
how to
regulate it there has to be some
body of people and here's the hard part
to sell to people who have
absorbed the true lessons of the magic
of the market
is somehow the people with discretion to
say
what we cannot do what we must not be
allowed to do to each other using
technology
have to be independent of this you can't
be
you know a wealthy person with a stock
portfolio in which you're invested in
all of this stuff
and decide whether or not it's smart to
engage in these experiments the perverse
incentives are too many
and people are not uh even good people
are very difficult at managing
perverse incentives so i don't know how
we get there
but i do have the sense that in the end
either you have to forbid
the market to govern anything or you
have to have somebody who's immune
to market forces in a position to say
actually you can't do that because
you're going to derange people and
you're going to result in a tremendous
amount of
of harm right you can't do what
uh x in other words if somebody had
proposed
facebook and the idea is oh well
facebook is a
a place where people can gather across
arbitrary distances and talk about
topics they want to talk about
okay so far so good and you know they'll
be able to see
a feed of what their friends are doing
saying etc okay so far so good and now
that feed is going to be adjusted
according to an algorithm
that and then the answer is well what is
that
right at the point you begin to propose
the capture of attention
right something needs to say wait a
second here's what happens downstream of
that or you know what
we don't know what happens downstream of
that right so in other words
if we go back to your analogy about game
of gain of function research
we had a running battle about whether or
not gain of function research was
necessary in order to protect us from a
pandemic
or was more likely to cause a pandemic
than solve one
right right uh those of us who were on
the latter side of that
um didn't win and those of us
who were on the hey we've got to do this
i did
now is that the reason that we are now
fending off covet 19 and
losing the battle frankly somebody
needed to say actually
no because not necessarily here's the
dystopia that arises if you do this but
we don't
know what arises if you do this right
precautionary principle
yeah precautionary principle which is i
admit
difficult to instantiate well
but some version of it has to govern us
and this is kind of an age-old argument
between
you know allowing markets are just
another form of evolution so do you just
allow
system and technology to just you know
let people build things and you know fix
it later
versus when do those things have the
capacity to cause irreparable harm
and we should instill the precautionary
principle and say let's not just jump
ahead and you get the kind of
techno-libertarians that
just want to um you know build build
build no regulation deregulate
everything but again i think what we're
finding is
we have to be able to spot when the
things that we're proposing building are
closer to this sort of
um i don't keep referring to getting
functions i hope people don't center
that's the center point of our
whole conversation here or what it could
mean but i just
that there are dangerous forms of
tinkering that
if you're doing social tinkering or mind
you know
meaning making tinkering or social group
tribalist tinkering which all of these
things facebook had engaged with
um you could cause some you know some
some real harm and there has to be some
process by which we
stopped that but there was another thing
you were saying about speech and the
nazis and the paper and the pens
i want to make sure we're at least
acknowledging a principle
that we can i think agree to and and
want to honor which is that
you know to whom much is given much is
expected or with great power comes great
responsibility and the greater the power
the greater the responsibility and
accountability
and we went through a decoupling of that
and i'm really borrowing this from
daniel uh schmachtenberger and this is
this is his insight
uh not mine but uh you know i can go to
a uh
a kitchen store as a nazi or as a
regular person and i can buy a set of
knives
knives can be used to kill people but
they don't do a background check they
don't force me to do knives training
they don't have you know
i can just do that because there's a
limited degree of harm that i can
instantiate as an individual
and even though it sucks we have a court
process to later
be able to find those people etc
whatever but if i'm gonna buy a gun
um we have the you know second amendment
so i guess we have a fair equal access
to guns but we also have background
checks we have id checks we have
sometimes cases of you know training and
and that's required to wield these kinds
of weapons
but if you're going to buy a tank or buy
a bio-weapon manufacturing system or
ammonium nitrate or what these other
things
then we don't just say hey everyone gets
access to that or if you're going to
again do gain of function research or
have access to ammonium nitrate or
have any of these other things we have
to make sure that we're putting
protections around it
so now with speech i think we have this
temptation to say speech is just speech
but if i'm actually broadcasting to 100
million people
and i'm ability to do that unregulate
with it with no regulation no
no limits no you know i can say whatever
i want i can say it with the most
malicious intent uh i can i can do
consequential analysis i can run
you know gain a function you know
simulations on what i could say that
would cause different tribes to react in
the exact same way i can literally build
a machine that's generating speech and
split testing it across
trillions of simulations knowing the
communities that respond to my messages
in which ways and i can engineer almost
like
lab generated red meat political red
meat that i'm going to throw into the
ecosystem
and so i'm in other words i'm doing kind
of gain of function political research
on
what would cause the most havoc the fact
that i can do
that degree of memetic manipulation and
cause global chaos at that level
and there's literally no distinction
between the responsibility of someone
with 100 million
followers on twitter and someone with
10. i think we've lost the principle of
to whom much has given much is expected
or at the very least if you compare
standards for broadcast abroad tv
broadcasters who reach maybe a million
people in a local area
they face more regulations and standards
than we grant online and so i think
these are new kinds of services even
facebook is very different than twitter
in terms of text communication versus
you know
the kinds of posts that you can make on
on facebook but we're certainly missing
that principle that the responsibility
accountability standards and practices
are are needing and i would put that in
the list of
the agenda of the constitutional
convention that i believe is necessary
to make this
civilizational infrastructure more
democratic and globally governed for for
the public interest
public good well i agree with a lot of
that i sort of feel like we need a
constitutional convention and we
certainly cannot afford to have one it
will end up a disaster if we do
so the answer is we need something to
reckon with
things at that scale yeah um one of the
things that i say
about the the market what what is the
market
what can we allow it to do and what
shouldn't we is that there's a
natural distinction between the
following things markets are
excellent at figuring out how to do
things and they are appalling
at figuring out what should be done
right they tend to do things like
exploit defects in your personality find
weaknesses
amplify insecurities in order to make
money
and we can't let them do that it's not
it's not kind it's not decent
so right so there has to be some sort of
um
human discretion on what do we allow the
market to do
and then there has to be liberty to
allow the markets to do things but the
other thing that i'm increasingly
compelled
of is that we have a process
in which once things show themselves to
be profitable
they cannot be reversed right that the
political dynamics are such that once
you've made a huge profit at something
you're unstoppable so we can't go in
reverse
and that is in and of itself an
existential threat
i can i won't i won't do it here because
we're pressed for time but
that will actually cause the equivalent
of
senescence it will grow feeble and
collapse
because of that dynamic and so
i mean it is amazing look at the
technology we are using to have this
conversation
right we are almost as if face to face
having a conversation
in real time which will be broadcast to
hundreds of thousands of people
okay that's an amazing level of
technology and yet
we cannot figure out how to stop a
technological process
that everybody's smart understands is
putting us at existential risk
you can unplug it right and you know the
problem is even to you and me i'm sure
the idea
of tech platforms being unplugged
because civilization depends on them
being unplugged is almost unthinkable
but how did we get to the place where
there are processes that we have
unleashed in the world
that are both a threat to us and
inconceivable that they could be
unplugged
yeah there are days when i just think we
need to unplug these things and i
actually want to make a distinction
because what we're doing right now is a
good example of
i think a much more humane technology in
the sense that
um our representation to each other the
fact that i'm making
almost eye contact with you the fact
that my trustworthiness and
the credibility of what i'm saying and
how i'm saying it would be very
different than
i think when you think about the medium
of twitter or facebook if you were sort
of harboring really crazy views or
whatever
you would have almost an inflated sense
of credibility talking about those
things
in those medium because they subtract
away how credible does that person look
when they're saying all those things and
i think if you were to reverse
the last 15 years and you just had zoom
conversations you had zoom conversations
that were deep like this there were two
hours long
you had even 10 20 people on them would
we see
the kind of mass bifurcation of reality
i mean we still would have partisan
media i want to make sure i'm
acknowledging all that
et cetera but would we have the mass you
know fractal you know
fracturing of reality would we have um
the degree
of sort of out there crazy town kind of
thinking that we have
uh would we have you know i just don't
think we would have those things because
we would be
in these long-form mediums where we can
say wait hold on but i want to make sure
i understand you correctly were you
saying this or are you saying this
now we need modeling of that kind of
turn taking too we need modeling
of good epistemic process but that's i
think the thing that you're doing with
this podcast and that others are doing
and i think
this kind of medium is much more humane
than something that is an automated
gain of function research sort of uh you
know tinkering with human evolutionary
instincts and then letting things go
you know basically pandemic mimetics
it's a pandemic memetic complex that's
what it does is it creates this sort of
global spread of information
algorithmically that was not safe this
something this
is much more akin to safe and i would
prefer if i could pull the plug and you
asked me at another
thing we saw each other out like i think
about two years ago you know
you'd be one of the few people i would
trust to kind of pull the plug and in
some ways i think this would be
a plug i would be willing to pull is to
take away the sort of algorithmic social
media
and leave ourselves with this sort of
long form you know podcast like
long zoom conversation like with even
100 200 people listening and
interacting that would be a much better
world to live in
um this is going to be a marvelous point
to end on because it sort of
wraps up much of what we have been
discussing because
the point i would add to what you just
said which i 100
agree is that there is a reason this is
safer
it's not arbitrarily safer it's safer
because this treads
it is fully technological in every way
but
it allows your built-in heuristics as a
human being
to function right in other words
somebody who was
standing three feet from you and me
talking at a cocktail party
were we to have the same conversation
would have the same ability to evaluate
are these people full of [ __ ] do they
know what they're saying to each other
are they attempting to persuade
others of their credibility do they have
a financial interest here that isn't
obvious
you could make that evaluation in a
normal room and it would you know it
wouldn't necessarily be right but
it would be plausible that you could do
it you have enough information to go on
and so anybody tuning into this
conversation will be able to detect
for example they may not perfectly be
able to detect whether
there are any edits i don't think
they're going to be any edits here but
they will be able to see whether the
conversation flows as if unedited
they will be able to tell that you and i
are responsive to each other that
neither of us is
working from talking points because each
point follows from the next in a very
natural way
and so the point is your your built-in
set of heuristics for how human beings
sound when they do
or don't know what they're talking about
is applicable here
in a way that it can't be when things
are spliced together and an algorithm is
playing an unknown role and the
algorithm is
changing and you can't even detect that
if your heuristic worked yesterday it
might not work tomorrow
right all of those things are the
challenge and the closer things look
just as with diet the closer things
look to what your ancestors have been
eating the more likely they are to be
well
dealt with by your system and by the way
everything you're describing when we use
the word humane in
our founding of the center for email
technology it actually comes from um
my co-founder aza rask and his father
jeff raskin started the macintosh
project at apple
and the primary notion that humane means
being respectful of human
vulnerabilities and essentially
understanding what was what was um
adaptive about
all the evolutionary architecture that
you would want to express in its fullest
capacity health in a healthy way that's
where we need to look
to get this kind of dimensionality this
kind of of outcome like you said so just
to say that
the philosophy you're talking about is
exactly what we say when we think about
you have to be looking not at what would
make technology more sophisticated
how can we be more sophisticated about
human nature and the evolutionary roots
that got us here
in a healthy way and how can we
reappropriate more and more of those
lessons
i think that there's interesting people
across the board that are doing this i
think we need to do this kind of mass
excavation for the
babies we threw out with the bathwater
of other cultural traditions i mean i
think it's even some of jordan
peterson's stuff of taking personal
responsibility as simple as it is
these are kind of um wisdom hacks that
bolt onto the human evolutionary system
uh one more that i might leave you with
that one of my favorite ones recently
is the serenity prayer the notion that
you know god gave me the wisdom to uh
i'm gonna watch it what is it god gave
me wisdom to
know the things that i can't change to
accept the things that i can't
and have the wisdom to tell the
difference if you think about that
i'm curious if you agree with from an
evolutionary perspective
in the evolutionary ancestral
environment on the savannah
attention was coupled with agency i put
my attention on that rock i can move
that rock
my attention i put that on that line i
can run away from the line
so what i put my attention on is
directly coupled with
um what how i can act in relation to it
and so our our brains don't naturally
distinguish when we put our attention on
things between what we have
agency to do something about versus that
which we don't
and that's why you know i think of that
that serenity prayer that wisdom prayer
as a sort of bolt-on humane technology
that says hey your mind in this new
environment
doesn't make that distinction so we have
to remind ourselves
to point our attention to things that we
can change and
humane technology is like that it's
based on an insight about the fact that
our
attention is agency blind or
non-discriminating
and that we need help to put our
attention on the things that we have
agency over just to leave
the audience maybe with an optimistic
vision is imagine a humane
social media or you know other sort of
digital technology
that is helping us put our attention on
the things that we can actually
change and that ladder up to bigger
changes in a world in which every single
time we use technology it's helping us
put our attention on things that can
actually change and we can get on that
treadmill of positive feedback
of feeling like the daily choices we
make are leading to a better world for
ourselves for the people around us and
for the world
and that kind of attention economy is a
much better attention economy
than the one we have today which is
basically infinite learned helplessness
because even if i'm pointing my
attention at the important stuff like
say climate change in a facebook news
feed it's basically yeah it's worse than
you thought and there's nothing you can
do and i can scroll my finger and see
it's worse than you thought nothing you
can do worse than you thought nothing
you can do
we want a world where we have agency
over the things we put our attention
over and technology could make that the
default setting
as opposed to something you have to
consciously bolt onto your own
consciousness
wonderful i want to just point out the
flip side of it
so you're absolutely right that our
attention is essentially
scheduled to those things that an
ancestor would have had agency over and
they would be
programmed they'd be wired to ignore
everything that
there was no point in thinking about it
because there was nothing to be done
right
now the problem is if you're mark
zuckerberg
then you could make decisions about
algorithms that could plausibly end the
world
so your attention really be ought to be
on that hazard in a way
that an ancestor would never think about
it because there's nothing an ancestor
could do that would end the world
right right right there's no decision
that works that way um
or very very rarely you know you could
maybe screw up your you could take your
population across some
something or other and go extinct but in
normal functioning there was no mistake
you could make
that would have that kind of impact and
so we need to get these people
upgraded so they understand the
increased agency that they have and
therefore the increased responsibility
which i realize is
part and parcel of uh your your
formulation here
um so anyway okay i feel like we've had
uh
the introduction to a very good
conversation that we now need to have
we should definitely do something like
this again sometime it's been a
fantastic conversation i
really appreciate getting to dig into
these topics with you and go deep
great uh it's always great to talk to
you about this and
just to say in closing i do think there
are people who
can be trusted to think this way on
humanity's behalf
and you are very high on my list of
that small fraction of people who has
that kind of
wisdom and decency so anyway thank you
for all you do tristan
i really appreciate it and i look
forward to the next one
means a lot to me brad thank you so much
uh where should people find you
uh you can look up more of our stuff on
humanetech.com um you find me on twitter
at
tristan harris although i don't really
use it very much given um
kind of post social dilemma world um but
i think uh our podcast your undivided
attention is a great place to look for
for going more deep into some of these
topics
great um that's excellent uh we will
post links to those in the description
and uh be well tristan and to everyone
else thanks for tuning in
thanks so much
[Music]
you